it is now time for this week's pet
project lori is joining us from the
nspca and she brought along someone who
needs a safe and caring home and this
cat's name is blt and i have to know
where the inspiration for blt came from
lori
it's so cute
so our staff gets really creative with
some of the names so i'm not really sure
rocky maybe it was just a day before
lunch
craving i have to say that um it's one
of my favorite sandwiches and now it's
one of my favorite cats so this handsome
10 year old is blt and um i want to
first say tell the audience that while
you look rocky like you've obviously
been to the spa blt has not but he's
going tomorrow so tomorrow if you adopt
him he's going to be all
cleaned up and shaved he did come from
one of our transfer partners but that
rescues sociable cats from outdoors so
he's been outdoors and um needs a little
cleaning up he is a very lovable guy
that you can tell he loves his wet food
he loves to be held like a baby and he
loves his favorite toy like like we all
do right oh my gosh i'm falling in love
with blt lori
he's such a good boy he's praying right
now oh okay well tell us what kind of
home that blt will need
so he's very sociable he is um 10 years
old so somebody that can give him just
that little extra attention because he
does require some
oral and eye medications he has a
condition called hyperthyroidism
but he would actually be a good fit for
a lot of homes he's
really easy to get along with with both
people and pets and because he's a
senior of course he would qualify for
our senior for seniors program where the
adoption fees are waived to our human
seniors ages 65 and up
he is as you can tell
i love blt can you tell us really quick
before we wrap up how people can get
involved with the calendar
yeah 2022 calendar entries are done as
of this monday so enter your pet now at
nevadasvca.org and your pet could be the
star on the 2022 calendar for nevada
spca thank you so much lori blt we'll
see you later if you're interested in
adopting a pet go to nevadaspca.org or
call them at 702 873